let's speak to Professor Julio my own
he's a medical director at a hospital in
Madrid dr. mayo thank you so much for
joining us this morning here in the UK
what is it like in your hospital well it
is it's a bad situation it is really bad
and it's getting worse day by day after
day because the number of patients
coming nineteen positive patients is
increasing we have a lot a larger number
of patients and the problem is we can
increase the room available we can
provide them with more bets but but we
need we need a PP years we need personal
protection equipment and there is a
global sausage and this makes it very
difficult for us to send health care
workers to borrow in the front line
without the adequate equipment this is
really serious and secondly healthcare
professionals are getting infected and
15% I estimate that it may be like 25%
in the near future if we don't do
something and this is going to be a huge
crisis it's not going to be easy have
you had colleagues in that hospital
there who have tested positive for
covered 19 yeah most right now two of my
closest collaborators are come with 90
positive um so so it is becoming a
nightmare
many of our doctors are were admitted
and even those fighting the virus er
very very closely so nurses are also a
major problem for us especially for
those in the ICUs
if we don't get the right of personnel
to handle this ICU patients
is going to be almost impossible to
increase the number of ICU beds because
we don't have trained personnel to take
care of our patients okay um I can't
understand what that situation is like
doctor what is your advice to countries
looking at your country and seeing what
you're going through now and trying to
get ready for whatever is coming what is
your advice to them yes we faced we were
in the same situation you are right now
several weeks ago and it was easily
before us so so we were just saying
these things going on and we did little
and that was a big mistake at least in
retrospect so first of all stay at home
try to increase and enter and to really
go into social distance and increased
social distance was your hair was your
hands and try to build this firewall to
avoid this cute fire that is going to
take over secondly test as many people
as possible
starting with healthcare professional we
need to identify that identify those
into isolate those covered 19 positive
healthcare professionals to to face the
problem to tackle the problem before it
becomes this disaster and thirdly this
is not an NHS problem is not a space
health care system problem this is a
societal challenge and we have to work
in function as a society to isolate the
virus and in to avoid the
of lives and money